[Music]  okay everyone here  it's so awesome  [Music]  we should try to find out where we are  we need to be ready for whatever stands  ahead of us  what combat experience do you have in  your world copied a couple wrestling  moves that were explicitly said not to  try at home got it grab your swords  not everything in ever elm  is as it appears  [Music]  i know everybody here wants to win a  challenge do you trust everyone on the  team  [Music]  the magic of everelle  is everywhere  [Music]  you can redeem the sacred bond between  ever realm and the fate  there are eight ways in and only one way  out let's go  [Applause]  i think there's a bigger goal of end  than just winning  oh my gosh how do i get out of here  and now the quest begins  the quest  they're all very hesitant they were like  teenagers are going to help us save our  kids you're estimated  only  on disney plus